- Oh my god.
Hello angels!
Oh my, babies! (laughing)
^- [Interviewer] So, if you could name the dogs,
^what would you name them?
- Okay, Avenger.
We're gonna call you Nora.
Yeah.
Oh what is this one?
Huey.
I like it.
He seems like a Huey, he's just goofy.
(upbeat music)
Hi, I'm Brendon Urie from Panic! At The Disco.
And I'm gonna be answering your fan-submitted questions
while hanging out with puppies.
Let's see how well I can do.
(laughing)
Okay, here we go, first one.
Hi beautiful, hi beautiful.
Okay okay, let's answer these.
Okay, you wanna eat this?
Okay.
^"Since you've taken to Broadway acting,
^"is there any chance we could see you in other acting gigs?
^"Perhaps on TV?"
Well, if it involves dogs, absolutely.
I will do a dog film.
A Marley and Me, but opposite where I save all the dogs.
That's what happens.
Oh you're so sweet, goddammit.
Okay.
Pushing through, pushing through.
^"What's your favorite tattoo and why?"
Oh it's definitely, get outta there.
You lil stinker.
You wanna bite, you wanna bite?
It's definitely my one that I got of my wife's eye
inside of her favorite flower, which is the yellow rose.
I love that one, oh I'm sorry darling.
^"Have you seen Love, Simon?
^"And if so, what did you think about
^"Panic! being featured in it?"
I haven't seen it yet, I am going to very soon.
I was very flattered, a fan had tweeted me
a synopsis of all the mentions of Panic!
I remember getting the email like a year and a half ago,
we had talked about it,
and we signed off, it was under a different name,
I can't remember, but I was just like,
"Yeah this sounds like a really cool story,"
and then sure enough it ends up in the movie
and like, that's the coolest thing,
that's like, you know, the biggest compliment to receive,
especially a movie like that, just so forward-thinking,
I love it.
Oh my goodness, okay okay, we have a few questions left,
we'll just party for a little bit.
Oh my goodness, oh my goodness.
(growling and kissing noises)
^"If you could have one Panic! At The Disco lyric tattooed,
^"what would it be?
^"And where would you put it?"
Aw geez.
That's a tough one.
I would just put "close the goddamn door"
just right across my ass, you know what I mean?
Okay, great, that's (laughing), oh my god!
Oh you guys!
What's this?
Oh you sweetheart.
Hi, hi, let's get that keys, let's get that keys.
Okay.
^"Do fans ever quote your Vines to you when you meet them?
^"And which one is your personal favorite?"
Yeah, the first time I got recognized
for not being in Panic!, I went to a movie, I stepped out
and these two really sweet girls came up and said,
"Hey are you that guy from Vine?"
And it took me a second, that's the first time I was asked
and I was like, "Oh yeah, yeah I am, yes I am!"
and they started singing this coffee one that I had done.
♪ I need my coffee in the morning, baby ♪
♪ If I don't have it, it'll drive me crazy ♪
So that was very cool, thank you,
I think her name was Jessie.
Thank you.
Let's see, oh my god.
(laughing)
You're just lounging like a little boss.
Hi.
^"Would you ever consider doing another Broadway show?
^"And what would your dream role be?"
Absolutely.
I was raised in the Mormon faith,
so I would love to be an Elder Price, that would be great.
The only problem is I have a full sleeve of tattoos
and most missionaries are in short sleeves.
So, well see.
Make-up.
^"What made you decide to call your fans 'sinners'?"
Again, I grew up in the Mormon church and it was just
kind of a little juxtaposed to what I was taught.
I was always taught that I was a sinner, I'm no good,
I'm not good enough for Heaven, so I just think it's ironic.
It's funny.
^"How did you know that Sarah was 'the one'?"
First time I met her, she was not single,
and there was definitely a chemistry there.
But I knew that she was down and very cool
because I made her a Lunchable with a Capri Sun,
and she was totally down, it was like fancy to her,
it was like hor d'oeuvres, it was like a canape.
It was great.
^"If you could create or contribute to the soundtrack
^"of any movie, which one would it be?"
(laughing)
Dog movie!
Oh my goodness!
I think I've said it before, I would love to do
the overdub and the foley for a Jason Statham movie,
you know?
Where I do, like, all the punches.
(imitates punching noises)
"Oh God!"
And like, do this you know,
(puppy barking)
yelling and stuff.
(Brendon barking)
^"If you could choose one or two bands
^"to go on tour with you,
^"who would they be and why?"
Ooh, one or two bands.
Let's do, um...
(laughing and kissing)
I'm just a massive Kendrick fan,
Kendrick Lamar, that would be dope.
Just let me open, I'll do five minutes of stand-up,
I'll sell your merch, whatever bro.
Lemme hang.
^"What is the last thing you do before going on stage?
^"And the first thing you do coming off stage?"
Last thing I do before going on stage,
I watch the band hit the stage, I walk out,
it's usually just a rush of emotions.
But right before that we do our pre-show shot,
to kill the hyper-awareness.
We had done a whiskey shot, and it just all made us grumpy.
So, we realized whiskey wasn't the,
no brown liquor before the show.
So we do one shot of tequila
and then right after we come off,
my favorite way to come off the stage is an Elvis exit
which means you just go from stage, right into a van,
right to the hotel, into a shower, and pass out.
That's the best.
(laughing)
Dude it's just a show for me, I don't have to do anything.
^"Was there an audition process for Kinky Boots?
^"And if so, what was it like?"
Not really.
Which, I was nervous for.
I was flattered that they would give me the part
but I was very nervous for it.
Basically I had D. B. Bonds, who flew out to LA
he's the associate director for Kinky Boots.
He flew out for two days, we did an hour each day
of just reading through the script,
talking about motivations, that was pretty much it.
Then we had about a week of rehearsal,
teaching me the dance moves, putting my heels on,
and then it was showtime.
And my put-in rehearsal I dropped a glass on stage
and it shattered, and my heart shattered.
I was just like,
(gasping) "Hopefully that was the worst of it."
No, I would continue to fuck up, every night.
But it was fun, it was fun.
^"What is the most memorable, weird, thoughtful, et cetera,
^"gift you have received from a fan?"
Weird or thoughtful?
I got a voodoo doll,
which usually you would keep the voodoo doll,
but they gave it to me, of myself.
So you know, if ever I feel like,
what is that called, flagellating?
In a way, I'll just poke the doll and be correct.
^"What is the album's overall genre?
"Is it gonna be all-jazz like as what you've mentioned
"in one of your live sessions before?"
No, every song is different, I love doing that.
Yeah, they're kind of all over the place, you know?
There's one that feels like you're in a club
but it sounds like you're at a Hot Topic.
(laughing) I don't know.
If Hot Topic were a club I guess, yeah.
^"Would you ever consider writing another song with FOB?"
Absolutely, I love those guys.
I love, I love Fall Out Boy.
They're my homies.
They've always been really inclusive,
like including me in all their stuff
and they're just big brothers.
Oh, let's get the paper.
Let's get the paper!
^"What was some titles for this new album that you
^"thought about about but didn't end up going with?"
I was gonna call it, like, a Lord Byron quote,
which I thought was really nice.
It wasn't, "love not man less, but nature more,"
it was, "fame is the thirst of youth,"
which I thought was a really cool quote.
But, yeah, it's Pray For The Wicked,
I just thought that tied in everything actually,
that I was talking about.
^"What was your first impression of Pete Wentz?
^"Did you think you guys would have
^"the relationship that you have now?"
No, not at all.
Pete was very cool,
he was in LA making his record with Fall Out Boy
and I remember walking up and being like,
"Wow, this guy looks like a rock star."
And then we went back to the practice space
and played some stuff, oh that was a puppy fart.
Solid.
Alpo gas.
Yeah, I didn't that that we would, you know,
I didn't know what was gonna come of meeting Pete
and getting signed and all this stuff.
So yeah, it's just gotten better over time,
he's my big brother.
^"I am dying to know how the performances differ
^"between a Panic! At The Disco concert
^"and appearing as Charlie Price in Kinky Boots on Broadway?"
Very different.
I'll say the biggest difference
is that with a Panic! show, luckily the fans, you guys,
are louder than me sometimes and you save me in moments
where I might forget a lyric or a voice crack happens.
But in Kinky Boots, you're up there and spotlight's on you
and if you mess up, everybody hears it.
You're under a microscope and that was very exciting.
^"Coming from a person who deals with anxiety
^"and wants to become a performer one day,
^"how do you cope with anxiety on stage
^"or even during the whole touring process?"
^Very good question.
I used to take medication, then I stopped taking it.
I just came to a realization that I didn't wanna go there.
So then I adopted the art of breathing.
Breathing exercises, that really ended up helping me
a lot more than I thought it would.
Which is pretty great, so, thanks for that question.
I know performing can be very anxiety-driven,
so, I believe in you.
^"What is your plan for the future of Panic! At The Disco
^"after this album?"
I don't know.
I've talked about, like, doing weird stuff.
Like after the Broadway thing,
building a show like that, taking it on the road,
not necessarily with an album
but just kinda building the idea of a show.
It wouldn't just be an album, I don't know.
There's something there.
There's definitely something in there.
^"Favorite Fall Out Boy song or lyric?"
Right now, I like Church, that one's great.
♪ I get on my knees ♪
Great lyric.
^"Did you guys ever actually consider yourselves 'emo'
^"when you started as a band?"
No, we never did.
But, we listened to a lot of bands that were considered emo,
so yeah, we were never offended by it.
It's like if you wanted to call us emo, yeah all good.
^"Which person that you've met
^"or which interaction that you've had,
^"do you think has had the biggest influence
^"on how you want to be seen just generally as a person?"
Wow, that's a deep question.
I'm a believer in the butterfly effect, right?
So like, if I, you know,
everybody I come in contact with has an influence on
something that will happen in the future for me.
I got to meet President Obama and the First Lady,
that was, Michelle and Barack man, that was crazy.
Waiting in line, I was so anxious, then we stepped in,
me and my wife, and watching her meet them first I was just,
"This is actually happening, this is really crazy."
Very tall, very beautiful people.
Shook my hand and I just kind of shuddered a little bit
and I just said, "You are just great
"and I am a big admirer of yours, and just thank you."
And he said, "That's a very snappy suit."
And I thought it was great.
Okay, last one.
^"Would you ever be a judge on RuPaul's Drag Race?
"I feel like it would be a perfect fit for you."
Absolutely.
That would be a blast, are you kidding?
I would love to be a contestant on there too.
Yeah, we'll figure something out.
I just love to be in drag.
Yeah, Avenger's my dude.
Yeah, bro.
(laughing)
Yeah, dude.
Oh, you're the sweetest.
Yeah, you protecting me?
(laughing)
Hey, I just wanna thank Buzzfeed, man,
for setting this up, 'cause...
What?
This is the dopest thing ever.
Hey, by the way, you guys want to adopt?
^North Shore Animal League America.
Dude.
Take all four.
That's four times the happiness, bro, come on.
(laughing)
Hi!
You're getting all of this, yes?
I need this footage.
(upbeat music)